your phone hey guys we live we're live
relax okay so I want to tell a little
story of how we met is it's a little
interesting I um first of all I just
want to say I can't believe we're
revisiting this again some of you said
you wanted to hear this but for some
reason we had yeah I keep getting
comments like how did you guys meet some
we're finally gonna just have held them
okay so here I was you'll hear the truth
on this side which is my version which
is over here so here we I was in San
Diego I I was just starting out as a
chiropractor and so I didn't really know
what I was doing so I went to this swap
meet okay swap meet is like place where
they sell different you know junk food
and things are junk material and another
step to some cool stuff and so here I am
I met this swap meet I have this little
booth and I'm checking people right so
I'm in my car my Nissan Sentra eating a
banana and at the time and then I see
this girl come by and it was Karen with
her boyfriend so I check okay you're
with your next I actually went to the
swap meet to find a chiropractor because
I had some back trouble and my roommate
said that sometimes there were
chiropractors doing screenings at the
swap meet
yeah I was like the screening King so
anyway checked her I think she was the
only person who came in at the ton it
was the beginning of my practice I had
no patience she was like one of my first
patients okay she comes in yes it is
against the law to hit on and date your
patients in the nineties this is another
90 that's why in all fairness my
insurance had been used up and we were
no longer I don't know how to make this
right but I mean were you going with
that it was legal anyway so I I didn't
have any patients today so I pretty much
gave her a consultation that lasted all
day it was an all day as myself and
hours of well let me do some extras here
after is there so anyway things you put
me in a in a house
gown I never know chiropractor to do
that well that's what you do when you
take x-rays okay yeah so so anyway she
started coming in so you started getting
improved in it and I was interested in
her so I decided to ask her out
and the first opportunity that happened
was she comes in she tells me that she
broke up with her boyfriend so in my
mind I'm like hmm she's probably hinting
that she's single now and asked me yeah
that's what's going out of my mind any
guy would say that right now but so
basically I asked her out and she says I
get rejected okay I get rejected okay I
said would you like to go to lunch and
then she says well now you're probably
bill me okay so so this is the truth how
it really went down is that I had when I
said just broke up I mean like in the
parking lot there was you know an
emotional moment and I came in for my
doctor's appointment and I was still a
little leaky okay and he was in the
middle of providing a treatment on my
spine noticing I was a little leaky and
said what's going on and I said that I
had just had this breakup and obviously
all my attention is still on this other
person and he says well if you need to
talk about it I am about to break you
know and I'd be happy to listen or
something like that in my mind I'm like
I'm already paying out of my pocket for
these visits I I don't even I don't want
to download my garbage to my doctor but
in his mind he's asking me on a date so
question number one to you guys do you
think that that's really asking me out
on a date I could listen more to your
problems so you have to have some
feedback on that go ahead miss feedback
if you think I'll do the a scanner I
really or the interpretation that wasn't
really an ask out or asked it wasn't
interpretation so ever no questions
brought something up that's interesting
so I thought at the screening
you were already broken up
so now you're saying you know right so
we weren't dating when you're dating and
then you know he knocked on the door
again and then that didn't work out I
think this is gonna really depend on if
there's guys watching their girls
because if someone comes in and they're
saying oh come on guys
if you well let's see what they're
saying okay I don't know how to not a
date someone says in his mind am i
delusional
not raised like we don't communicate
well actually we're awesome i
communicating we're talking about a
really funny time so okay dr. Berg was a
savage it was a subtle the moment okay I
think these are cat you're letting me
down Joe I got your back
Oh doc from James that was not that was
not a date
okay okay so not a date heck yes see
it's kind of a mixed bag isn't it's a
mixed bag all right so here's what
happened next so rejection number one
okay but I was I was persistent
so now number two rejection number two
right it was my favorite so I'm actually
doing what's called a genie rub which is
a massage tool back okay and and then
what happens is that I asked her out on
a date where I said would you like to do
some yoga I thought I was doing yoga at
the time I thought it was a great place
to meet on a date miss to yoga right and
rejection number two she declined okay
so this is what really happened it is
true I came in again for my visit
I'm on my stomach and he's doing this
big genie rub massage tool on my back
hair getting caught in the motor I fixed
that i undid the nut and he says to me
he's my chiropractor right he says to me
have you ever considered yoga and I who
I haven't ever
considered yoga I said no so that was
the rejection right okay I had to go out
this correct
the survey did you guys think was that
actually me asking her out or not not oh
no this is the last one
Mars and Venus someone says that was not
asking her out
that was the comeback oh wait that was
the first one that was first one hi
Manuel he's watching gosh what is anyone
oh not man I gotta go to medical school
um not poor attempt doc that was not
asking her to come out right directly so
sort of are you in a crit I am an
Aquarius or I was Aquarius until they
changed the moons and the planet things
and knows focus okay focus um okay
sorry dr. Burke I have to side with
Karen no all right okay I got that
let me go to strike three okay two
rejections so I decided that I was gonna
give her one more opportunity to go out
with me so I was gonna ask her I was
gonna ask her out
so because three strikes you know she's
gonna be out the relationship is gonna
be done so the third time the third time
check this out third time I get on the
phone and I call her and I asked her out
on a date to go to a blues band
this isn't San Diego Pacific Beach I
think it was it's a great blues band
right down the street
would you like to go to a blues band and
if you don't say that's asking her out I
don't know what what is but I got
totally rejected she says I'm not
interested so that was it okay so there
is truth this is the first time there's
actually truth in what he says mm-hmm
right because he did call me and he did
ask me to a blues band I am going to
give you the
other data that he knew knows very well
occurred the omission
the omission which was he called me at
home at about 11 o'clock at night it was
it was 10:30 no it was core time I go to
a blues band do you go at nine o'clock
until later this is the first time he
called me it was almost 11 o'clock at
night in the middle of the week I was in
my pajamas already and actually I was
working on paperwork I had to be at work
5:30 in the morning the next morning do
you know how many hours it took me to
get up the nerve to call you I was
waiting all day I know I know and I and
that I appreciate I get that but it was
11 o'clock at night
I was in my pajamas so it would take me
a good 20 minutes to get ready ready he
lived a good 20 minutes away Pacific
Beach was like 20 minutes away so we're
talking about almost an hour till I get
there and then the ban and then get home
and get to bed so this was primarily the
reason I was gonna have to pass on this
but with sealed the deal on the know is
that his roommates at the time now he
lived in an apartment on the beach with
some other guys as he's asking me out in
the background I hear go for it Eric I
couldn't help it there there's through /
dudes and that's how they communicate so
anyway I will say that contributed to my
certainty on the know but most of it was
the fact that you did ask me out so you
can you can get yeses what are they
saying
too late doc see right 11 o'clock in the
middle of the week you don't call
someone at the last minute for a first
date definitely right okay these call
right yeah okay right so the timing
wasn't the best okay so you want to know
how to ask someone out on a date in the
middle of the day I saw him that should
touchy because you know asking your
patient it's kind of like so I had to do
a little indirectly so if you like
freaked out I would say what I didn't
ask you out I was just wondering if you
like do yoga
[Music]
just kidding so cya so basically we got
three strikes zero that's it and now I'm
like I'm it's kind of like in high
school you know you like someone the
more you like them the more they don't
like you and then the minute that you
decide that you don't like them now
they're interested but I always have him
but after our relationship after our
relationship
three strikes I'm pretty much deciding
it's over okay and during this period of
time I was trying to build the rapport
because I used to do a little mini
seminars in my office and with and then
I asked her to help out which you didn't
really have I would used to pass out
champagne and cookies because I had a
fear of public speaking so I figured if
they drink champagne they would feel
more relaxed and it laughs at my jokes
so anyway so anyway we're we're at the
point of three strikes she's out I'm
done with the relationship and then it
was it was Christmas time and she was
going home but she gave me a Christmas
present she made these unbelievable
chocolates which I'm looking to select
oh my gosh she made these for me I made
him do everybody I didn't know that I
thought oh my gosh she does like me
right
she gives me these these chocolates and
then she walks out and she gives me the
look the back look and she's coming
around she's walking out and then she
looks back boom I knew right there
there's something there she I think she
does like me I did like you so I'm like
okay so so I go back to Wisconsin now
that would have been the time to ask me
out well I you already have you three
chances yeah so that was so but so I'm
gonna let go you know and if she's
interested she can ask me some like you
know anyway I did I called him up asked
him to my business holiday party he came
and so basically well was there any type
of lag time of neighbors snow as a
matter of fact I was saying Oh dr. Berg
you know scaring and no you're
relatively new and
I'm new in town and my company's having
this you know and I just thought you
know your chiropractor these guys are
physical therapists occupational
therapists because that was my
profession occupational therapy maybe
you know there'd be some interest and
reality and you know I'm like okay he's
like okay like well let me tell you what
it is it's like no okay I'll go okay
yeah so so one last little part of this
right the night that we were supposed to
go I was doing another screening right
you're not gonna tell this oh no just
this last little part here I'm doing
this little screening and I'm like oh my
gosh it's it's late I got a run so I get
in my car I get to my apartment and
guess what
I locked my keys in the apartment I
forgot the keys it is dead bolted okay
what
so there is a there's a pine tree
okay next to my second-story apartment
with a slightly open I said when yelled
yeah the window I scaled that pine tree
Karen for you I scaled it all the way up
got in there got my keys and of course
you know arrived at the door this
explains why one time he was on time and
looking amazing but it did explain why
your sleeves were rolled up and you had
big globs of SAP in your arm I cleared
it off you weren't supposed to see that
okay so anyway anyway for the rest of
you call it fate but we both worked kind
of hard at that one it worked out yeah
all right god yeah so that answers the
question yes you were yesterday you
weren't interested there you go you have
it and I'm sure you guys will all agree
that you didn't ask me out three times
yeah I'm going to be looking at the
comments I think probably most the guys
will we'll do that alright guys thanks
for watching and we will see you next
time have a good one